paris
vous voyez nos amis alors j'ai 30 ans
télévision mais c'est la première fois
que je vois un plateau de cette qualité
comment allez-vous vieux bourg et des
bas ils demandent si tu as pas une place
dans ton émission pour lui passer à tout
ce qu'on mange absolument guérin en ce
moment est un peu et leur la magie je ne
sais pas par quels instituts et les
passes et mairie fait 30
ouais bon alors comment tu vas toi aussi
bien que toi
ouais on est sur une chaîne béni nous
sommes nous avons la chance d'avoir des
directeurs merveilleux je dis ça parce
que j'aime les croisières police ray ça
va quoi non savent pas combien même je
suis je suis complètement ébouriffés
partant des corps mais complètement
ébouriffés sauf que c'est génial
alors moi je t'ai connu dans une
émission très très difficile très hard
et ready stroy qui s'appelait un égal 3
c'était coûté la première émission
comique que j'ai fait avec jean yanne on
en a fait 3 et à la 4è on nous a virés
ah oui c'était comme ça à l'époque ça
n'a pas changé mais c'est devenu plus
cool c'était kim pdg à l'époque je sais
plus tu sais les pdg ça change alors
après il ya eu quand même la lorgnette
c'est une petit rapporteur il ya eu les
dimanches
s'il ya eu les dimanches oui mais je
trouve un peu plus respectable quand
même qu'avant tu étais un peu rangé des
voitures et tu as dit d'ailleurs la fin
de l'insolence c'est le commencement de
la vieillesse est-ce que tu atteins
j'avais d'une femme vêtue elle dit ça
absolument ans entre guillemets est-ce
que tu n'as pas l'impression d'être
devenu un peu trop respectable quand tu
regarde pas mes émissions jusqu'au bout
parce qu'avec la nouvelle émission 26 à
peine assis font foi on a déjà eu pas
mal de lettres recommandées
ce qui prouve que on a retrouvé le temps
mais je vais pas te reprocher de faire
une émission qui marche parce qu'on rêve
tous de faire des émissions qui marchent
aussi bien que la tienne mais est ce que
finalement à après quinze ans de
dimanche martin qui va pas un peu comme
au boulot quoi ah non je me marre ou
alors parce qu'on a une excellente
équipe
ouais on vit dans un merveilleux théâtre
et tu sais par expérience que aucune
émission ne ressemble à une il ya
toujours l'inattendu
les jours avec et des jours sans je
pense que faire de la télévision est un
métier extraordinaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens je rêve d'en
faire
j'espère qu'ils n'en font pas trop tôt
pour jour est encore battu ali des fois
par exemple je me regarde faire ce que
tu te bats pas faisons quand l'émission
quand bien sûr on se regarde le faire
c'est tout à fait normal mais la chose
que je n'ai jamais fait c'est de me
regarder la télévision
je ne peux pas supporter alors ceux qui
même un peu baby a suffi d'un qui
commence pas alors tel client idéal pour
double jeu parce qu'en fait ils jacques
martin qu'on voit tous les dimanches
après-midi qu'on aime qu'un tas de gens
regardent et puis effectivement il ya
l'autre suit les passionnés par la
musique par la littérature
quand tu fais quoi pour la musique parce
que moi j'ai entendu dire je suis pas en
province là où j'ai ma maison jean
teulière s'était vu un dimanche après
midi jeu argentin je suis venu donner un
concert spirituel dans la cathédrale
pour la société de musique d'argentan on
a fait un concert prokofiev vrai on a
joué une pièce de mozart qui n'est pas
trop connu enfin de donner un concert et
ça a permis à la société musicale
d'argentan de reprendre pied
faut dire que tu termines
l'enregistrement de dimanche martin le
samedi soir et je pars en salle de
concert le dimanche
et j'adore ça je dois être crevé non pas
du tout non mais je m'éclate
il ya un autre jacques martin c'est
celui qui lit parce qu'on dit toujours
tu peux résister
on dit toujours ça fait partie de la
légende que tu peut réciter des pages
entières de mark twain dessous et le pin
terms
la lecture est une mauvaise habitude
qu'il faut prendre très jeune ouais je
pense que mon enfance ayant été une
enfance très très malheureuse est très
solitaire je me suis réfugié dans la
dans les livres et jolie depuis depuis
l'âge de raison je crois que je vis dans
l'élite depuis l'âge de huit ans et
c'est une mauvaise habitude que j'ai
conservé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais cette gêne pas que les gens ne
connaissent que celui que que tu
appelles la bonne à tout faire du
dimanche après-midi le teil de ton
émission l'indicatif judge tout le monde
joue un double jeu qui n'a qu'une
personnalité legris antilles pour
doubler angers dijon j'ai plusieurs
double jeu mais tous les êtres humains
sont douze il ya l'apparence et à l'être
intérieur il ya dix ans le moal sur moi
pour faire attention et c'est vrai qu'on
dit souvent êtes cultiver pour un
animateur
oui voilà vous êtes prof pour un
sénégalais c'est exactement la même
chose
on me dit je faisais il y avait thani
20h01 c'est pas s'ils pensaient pas
dérangeant comme disait courteline c'est
une volupté d'être pris pour un imbécile
dans ses comptes en fait c'était pas
empêché quand même d'écrire et blanc
parce qu on l éponge qui rament une
chanson qui m'a payé ma première voiture
à hewitt conneries ça paye une voiture
tandis qu'une chanson intelligente ça
paye même pas assez gourmand et blanc
passe mal étrange c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
de la poésie française va nous le faire
oui je peux te dire le port est mais
vichy
l'autre samedi ma femme germaine me dit
tu vas prendre un bain ça fait bien plus
de vies semaine que tu ne t'es pas laver
les mains c'est beau quand même près et
le refrain c'est blanc passe moi
l'épongé
et vlan fais-moi gligli et vlan passe
moi l'épongé
et vlan et c'est là la trouvaille
bouzigues aussi qu'il faut une joie les
argoviens
c'est pas tout ça quand même de passer 2
et blanc passe moi l'épongé a pint
heures de painter à amiens voilà c'est
enfin voilà qu est de tout ça à l'
empire
t'es pas dans la vie doit être curieux
est ce que tu es quelqu'un de stressé au
fond je l'étais mais je le suis c'est
qu'à une échelle du stress il paraît que
ça peut tuer